what are you doing here in Somerville
anyway honestly my mom won't say it but
we're completely broke and the only
thing that's left in our name
this is creepy old farmhouse I
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value what is that somehow a town that
isn't anywhere near a tectonic plate
that has no fall lines no fracking no
loud music even is shaking on a daily
basis
I remember that one summer we died under
a table I found this in my living room
[Music]
chiller replica a replica of what a
ghost trap there hasn't been a ghost
sighting in 30 years New York in the
eighties it's like The Walking Dead your
dad never mentioned this to you it's
just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the Rob loves
life
well
[Music]
who are you
call it fake
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
[Music]
that everything happens for a reason
come on darling
it has a Connor seat
you